[Music]
we
know we all know 2020 has been
the best year ever bananas
and oranges great for content bananas
is it yeah i don't like the content i've
been seeing i know it's sad but
it's a lot of it too much it's been
heavy a lot of bad news a lot of like
like what everything's been great okay
joe we know
we know you're kidding
maybe in the joe world it's been great
but we're talking about the actual world
though
there's [ __ ] outside there's kids in
cabinets and [ __ ] that's sad
kids in cages people dying left and
right from coronavirus everyone's sick
and apparently the plague the exactly
place but i've been telling you guys
that this has been happening
it's just now that people are seeing it
that's the difference
it's not like it hasn't been happening
before i mean the pandemic is pretty
unique
that's the only thing well anyway
2020 is known as like a really crazy
year right
so like i said it's been nothing but bad
news left and right is what it feels
like so here's some good news
oh thank you we're gonna we're gonna be
talking about some good news
no sgn no vice did this like
article where they were just talking
about like some good [ __ ] that happened
in 2020 so first thing on the list here
is
all of parasites oscar wins you know the
movie
parasite oh yeah kind of cool what about
the what about the oscar ones yeah you
know
they like won everything this is the
person i won they took home like
the major awards that's pretty cool yeah
yeah
he had a great speech too great speech
very classy what did he say
he said listen [ __ ] um if you
cannot understand me
[ __ ] you and then his translator
actually said that when he won like uh
i think best director or whatever like
not only did he like
ex like um accepted the award but he
also like humbly accepted it by
mentioning other directors and like
giving like
them praise like well if it wasn't for
these guys who inspire
inspired me oh that's dope like
tarantino and his feet mm-hmm
it was classy fetish yeah he didn't say
that well he put the feet fetish for him
in the movie
he did yeah when she was in the back of
the car on the phone being like oh we're
gonna have a party after he just lost
his home
and she had her her feet up in his face
and that's when he was like [ __ ]
boiling
moving on to the next thing uh
coronavirus
art you know like is that good we get to
see
like versions of like
art but now it's being influenced by
this pandemic
that's kind of cool it's just you know
there's art inspiration i mean
art's supposed to be reflective i like
the italian restaurant
and then they had a david with a mask on
like this
on his penis that would have been funny
but it was just his neck up
yeah because you know right before 2020
when we had that ridiculous
story of a hundred and twenty thousand
dollar banana duct tape to a wall
at heart yeah yeah yeah yeah now we're
getting like some cool [ __ ] so
there we go coronavirus art all right
the next one which is my personal
favorite
the rise of animal crossing
people has been playing that like crazy
[ __ ] yeah i have a switch
but it's only for pokemon crossing
listen i love animal crossing so much
but don't do it
people don't touch it you get sucked in
you have no life after
that's it that's it my life is animal
crossing that's why i don't buy any game
consoles
good yeah animal crossing crossing is
really interesting you just end up like
wanting things that like you don't
actually want
yeah it's like it's like real life well
i got to collect all the surfboards
i'm literally buying all the [ __ ]
umbrellas that's pretty funny everything
every single color variation
of every outfit how's that different
from our life now
well because it's a video game joe it's
escapism at its finest
and also there's a lot of like
creativity happening you know
this is my life depicted right now in a
meme
your walls are falling off falling down
yes it is
but but yeah animal crossing animal
crossing's been the best thing
ever but also the worst because no life
but anyway
moving on to the next thing or it is
life oh in a different world huh
true the next thing here wild
animals occupying the streets that's
pretty cool the streets are empty
dude i've been seeing so many [ __ ]
lizards and coyotes and like rats and
[ __ ]
damn dude actually yeah
the rat was actually a mouse and i was
just working out in my garage
and then this [ __ ] in front of
me goes
i don't give a [ __ ] and he just runs in
front and he goes into my boxes and i
was like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm here [ __ ] they really don't give a
[ __ ] one time
a little mouse ran across my feet across
your foot
like literally on your new house oh no
no this is when i was like
14. okay but yeah and i was like oh my
god
[ __ ] you i'm mickey i had no shoes on
either
i felt the little i saw one outside in
front of my garage and i think it was
trying to like go right into
inside the garage but then i think it
got scared and it was like
running up to it it was like [ __ ]
and you like completely backed away and
i was like what the [ __ ] just happened
like you
you were literally like two steps away
from just entering into the garage and
like you would have been lost
because his buddy last time the garage
closed
the guillotine rat you learned remember
on our way to the shooting range the
[ __ ] buddies that are trying to
commit suicide dude
god i
yeah hey you know i saw a snake too at
the shooting range
when i got there yeah i went to the
bathroom i came back and then
i was like that stick's moving oh that's
a snake and it just went right across me
all these guys are just going and
they're shooting and then the snake just
went sad
yeah that [ __ ] was in front of
me just going like this what kind of
snake
it was like a orange black one no it was
like a green
black one but it was like long stripes i
would try to catch it no but i don't
know if it's like gonna bite me and [ __ ]
but it was just moving and it just went
straight into the [ __ ] grass and i
was like
damn dude that's a snake i know it's so
crazy because a skunk showed up on our
in our doorbell camping whoa yeah i have
a little clip of it on my phone
on your front door yeah my front door it
literally went up to the front door
knocked twice was like hello with the
wildlife right i'm imagining
are humans just not scaring them
so they're more like they could [ __ ]
they're more comfortable
yeah we're just not out and about oh
you're speaking of [ __ ] not just
that but humans are [ __ ] war
at the hong kong zoo these panda pandas
that were notoriously
unhappy yeah i saw them they've been
[ __ ] like rabbits huh they've been
[ __ ] like
[ __ ] so we're gonna get more pandas
now maybe one panda express look at this
oh that's like doggy
panda sex breath panda panda style damn
he has her hat on her back like this too
apparently they just needed some alone
time yeah yeah maybe it was just too
many people watching them
they're like stop bothering me good news
in 2020 they're so
cute why are they august and jada
sorry yeah an entanglement i know
oh yeah that's cute it looks like two
stuffed animals did he just slap the
butt
i i saw it too at the end yeah why does
it look
like two stuffed animals oh it's just so
fluffy
technically are they gonna um hopefully
make a panda baby
yeah look at them he's like i want a
panda baby you're like trying to hold on
to her
i know a panda baby that would be so
[ __ ] imagine if we had pandas and
like
other kinds of animals aside from them
yeah they'll be sick dude
so much variety imagine we're watching
humans just [ __ ] like that oh it's so
cute humans do [ __ ] like this
dressed up as pandas and they're called
furries i think
aliens watch us and and they think that
about us they think we're cute
i think we're pretty ugly you're right
dude when i look at humans like we're
hairless like
[ __ ] ugly dude like animals animals
like [ __ ] dog
because if you think about a dog right
like i would say 99
of dogs are just freaking good looking
creatures yeah
right but when you look at humans maybe
about 20
look really good yeah why is it so much
variety of what
like in dogs they all look the same
pretty much
pretty much a chihuahua does not look
like a wolf okay like a german chocolate
german shepherds they all
there's not much variety well yeah
because they come from the same
breed like that's what i'm saying well
we're like the same breed
no no no no okay you look at this if you
look at afghans or like even my family
they all look different
completely yeah but it's like it's like
afghans or like i don't know like it's
an afghan hound and then the japanese
would be like a shiba inu right and then
the waiter
it looks different but so do the people
they look different that's what i'm
saying
why there's so much variety in that and
humans and dogs
because of the environment huh
environment
i don't know i don't know wait time okay
if you're looking you're sure
i gotta eat some chips dude i think i
think he's just saying that
like a german shepherd would look alike
huh german shepherds look alike yeah but
like if you look at them closely like
sometimes like
some eyes are like more narrow some are
literally and people would say asians
look alike
yeah so we are the german shepherds
because we look alike
not just asians they say that about most
ethnicities
and then there's like all different
kinds of chihuahuas that like their
chihuahuas but they all still look
different too there's one there's a
[ __ ] big-ass apple hood and there's
they look different but you look at them
you're like
yeah yeah right yeah just like us like
okay i'm wrong i'm wrong
oh you're wrong i chips again then
excuse me what's number six
well but the next one here is that
nature
healed while human activity chill i like
that that's a conspiracy that i believe
in that the corona came out because we
needed to heal the nature because we
were gonna have no more seafood and like
all kinds of [ __ ] was happening
yeah except for what leonardo dicaprio
posted recently about how the pandemic
is affecting us negatively because
there's people going to deforest the
amazon because there's less people
working to protect it right now
oh no really that's a bad reason hey
this is only good news
oh sorry yeah go away bad news yeah go
away go away
binges
yeah like for for example like how many
many many many cities around the world
are now reporting that they have
significantly less pollution or like in
the venice canals how you could see like
jellyfish and [ __ ] that's so nice
yeah it's pretty tight okay next one is
they put it on the pizza speaking of
pizza quarantine food trends
so a lot of people are experimenting in
their kitchen because now they just have
so much
free time i made this uh
mochi taro coconut and
um purple potato cake thingy wow yeah
it's really good because i wanted to eat
a ton of fiber
and then like i didn't even use any
sugar wow
nice it's pretty good it's gooey and
juicy it's kind of like a butter mochi
oh vitamin c is good butter
butter butter mochi yeah what what is
that it's one of my favorite ways of
eating
a mochi style it's kind of like a baked
mochi so imagine like a texture of a
mochi
but it's kind of like a cake cake yeah
like a dense cake
like a really like imagine like a cake
that's been pushed down and it's like
super
remember that one that we got in hawaii
from that dude that baked it on the
on the corner [ __ ] he had a booth
remember we were riding on the back
oh wait you weren't there okay what's up
i was riding him on the back of my
friend's pickup truck and i was like
stop
oh mr softy has it the butter mochi
the it's the ice cream place um in
monterey park cool yeah
so good try it i just googled it it
looks pretty good
next one is a new mode of working
so it says here for years people have
made references to the benefits of
working from home such as saving
commuting time increasing productivity
and creating a better work-life balance
companies were skeptical until the
coronavirus forced offices to shutter
indefinitely ushering a new era of mass
telecommuting
at first many were uncomfortable
unprepared and unmotivated by the
concept but after settling into the
group of working from home
many now prefer the new normal some
companies have even decided to let their
their employees work remotely after the
pandemic ends
that saves the money this only works if
[ __ ] speak english though
because there's some people they'll like
send me a message i'm like what the [ __ ]
are you saying i'm like i need to jump
on the phone because i don't understand
your goddamn english
and even sometimes on the phone doesn't
work i gotta facetime because i hear
weird noises and [ __ ] what's up with all
the little noises and background
you're too needy but then when you work
in person the communication i could feel
them
oh they're happy they're excited about
this project i'm like okay cool
i know how to take this information
sometimes you want them to respond
immediately too so you could
ask and then respond and then so that's
much easier
because when you text and you go away
what do you mean by that and then you
got oh i gotta type
so much that's why a lot of people like
i guess nine to five
typical office jobs it seems like it's
pretty awesome for them that they can
just work from home
they don't have to worry about like the
the traffic or child care that much
or whatever it is and then they schedule
meetings to
like zoom meetings or whatever to
actually conduct work i've also heard
some crazy ones where you're just
zooming the eight hours if you work a
nine to five
you just leave it on what so that you
know that instantaneous like hey so what
was that thing again
everyone has just instantaneous access
too and i'm like damn that's pretty
crazy a friend of mine just told me so
um she works in corporate world and she
was saying that
her boss like her superior is
like a super extrovert and she only gets
her social
like filling from from work like she
doesn't have any friends she lives alone
she doesn't have kids
and so she needs some debt this
supervisor
is scheduling out like zoom like
working on a like a puzzle or whatever
i'm exaggerating but like they're
actually an activity dude activities
to do and people are at home with kids
like
[ __ ] i have a toddler like leave me the
[ __ ] like it's sad for these
people that are really extroverted that
their only social
interaction is work get on a gaming
console or something
yeah yeah give her a [ __ ] red dead
redemption yeah go play with some kid in
some other country
i thought that would play right yeah
yeah it just sounds funny but i hear you
[Music]
you